Grid networks are also very important.
They represent the connectivity pattern you have
if you lay out a bunch of things as a grid
and connect them up, each one to their neighbor
sort of street-wise if this was a grid-based city.
Here's a particular example of a grid network
with 20 nodes--1, 2, 3, 4 times 1, 2, 3, 4, 5
and 31 edges if I counted correctly.
In particular, there are three edges to go across,
and there are 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 rows like that,
so that's 15, and there's 4 edges going down,
and there are 1, 2, 3, 4 rows like that
for 16 for a total of 31.
So just to make sure that you understand how to do this,
imagine we have 256 nodes arranged in a square,
and we connect up the nodes with edges in a grid pattern
just like this one here.
How many total edges do we have in the graph?